I'm in the UK a penguin which I'm
thrilled about because I think penguin
is the greatest book publisher in the
world and and England is the center of
the English language and that's really
something because England has brought a
tradition of truth and clarity to the
world that has illuminated it in many
ways and I'm hoping that this book
extends that great English tradition one
step farther like a good colonial should
so that's and I hope you read it and I
hope that it helps you sort out your
life I think people have found the
things that I have said helpful in that
regard and I've tried to distill them
and extend them in this book and deepen
them so hopefully that's what you'll
find when you read it